et ce alors que stars de la lune tweet
deux enfants et la muraille de chine
pays compte du québec tabakman
on dit que vous travaillez sur un
nouveau spectacle humoristique et
l'offre est immense en humour en ce
moment un coût plus grande que lorsque
vous avez commencé absolument la
compétition est beaucoup plus forte
comment fait sa place comme on retrouve
sa place c'est une bonne question c'est
à ce que je réfléchisse aussi et je
pense que je vais faire comme d'habitude
enfin la fin la plus personnelle
possible et je vais essayer de faire le
show que j'aurai envie d'aller voir une
jupe au but
quant à blanc conduit femmes taione au
numéro humoristique qui a fait 4 c'est
celui que c'est une seule ferme ta
gueule ouais la limite à metz allait pas
au huis clos pas complètement et en même
temps il faut que je regarde le matériel
qu'on faisait comme humoriste presque
prêt atteint maintenant je me demande
qu'est-ce qui tiendrait la route
aujourd'hui c'est sûr que maintenant on
vit dans une époque où on est vraiment
plus politique à l'est qu'à ce moment là
et pourtant nous à ce moment deux on
avait l'impression qu'on vivait dans un
moment où si tu ne t'étais parler
technique correcte qu'il faut les bras
c'est des choses si c'est drôle jamais
dire à ta blonde qui ont engraissé en
tailleur le referiez-vous ce numéro
d'aujourd'hui
oui absolument absolument moi je pense
qu'il y aura ni ne veut pas dire qu'ils
ne se poseraient aucun sujet ne serait
pas abordée mais si une grande leçon que
j'ai appris deux
le mot maître à penser de kaki yvon
deschamps c'est si au fond de tout ce
que tu dis dans l'oeil en arrière dans
il ya de la tendresse
ça va passer ça va marcher
lyon dont ils disent qu'ils veulent
combattre la corruption mais dans la
même pièce que des juges des avocats des
journalistes des constructeurs des
mafieux avec de poser des questions est
ce si beau les portes de canisses d'agde
a osé une allumette d'efforts c'est
toujours d'avoir beaucoup de tendresse
sympathie et mon personnage de l'agaci
me prouve à chaque fois qu'on peut dire
n'importe quoi mais vraiment n'importe
quoi sauf quiroga si les jeunes
connaissent il y ait un roulement
patrick huard vous avez déjà dit que
vous rêvez un jour d'avoir un oscar
entre les mains ce que c'est toujours le
cas c'est un rêve d'adolescence
moi je sais mon papa qui m'a fait
découvrir le cinéma particulièrement ce
rêve le est toujours présent c'est drôle
parce que les gens sont tellement de ma
gueule avec ceux ci on s'est vraiment
beaucoup foutu ma gueule avec ce pendant
longtemps et pourtant depuis il y en au
public québécois qui ont connu une
nomination aux oscars encore une fois
cette année
ces dernières années l école à bord et à
maintes reprises avec votre conjoint qui
négligent oui d'ailleurs ou à québec
cinéma on va présenter un titre court
métrage la porte
oui l'un encourage l'autre comment ça se
passe on dirait que tous les deux vous
avez un effet bénéfique
absolument absolument on est tellement
différent dans notre façon de travailler
que maintenant un nourrit la haute
c'est dur à expliquer comment c'est fou
comme maintenant qui on travaille sur un
projet on sait exactement qui a sa place
comme un où
justement vous parlez de la porte
j'étais son acteur judas son service ce
plateau de tournage la plèbe os mais si
artistiquement
c'était pas bon pour les deux on le
ferait pour moi je pense que c'est
l'amour qui va j'espère aussi j'espère
aussi mais en même temps je suis un peu
tombé en amour avec annick à cause de
son talent si ça vient avec ses 15
c'est un conte crise tombe en amour avec
son talent ici je sens vraiment sur
votre x plus en paix ce quelque chose
que changer artistiquement par leurs
professeurs parlent en douceur le sait
si bien c'est bien dit c'est vrai que je
me sens je me sens à ma place de quelque
chose qui s'est installé en moi que
j'arrive pas à décrire un monde mais je
me sens bien je me sens pas le besoin de
revendiquer des choses je lui fais je
sais le convainque les gens et puis en
direct depuis relaxer un peu les gens
sont plus convaincus de ma sincérité il
ya simple je veux faire des gens qui
jetaient un quart de civils
ça vaut déjà son bien aussi de me sentir
bien mais c'est un peu coupable et j'ai
pas peur que quelque chose arrive en se
disant ça se peut pas que ça dure
j'assume que ça va bien puis jamie foxx
a épié patrick roy remerciements merci 4
merci